for half a century Myanmar was one of
the most oppressive countries in the
world the military rulers crack down on
ethnic minorities locked up thousands of
dissidents and closed off the country
that's why Sunday's election was a big
deal it's not Myanmar's first vote in
2010 a civilian government heavily
linked to the military was elected but
there were widespread allegations of
fraud this time observers say the
elections were relatively smooth but
here are three reasons why this vote
isn't quite as democratic as you might
think the National League for Democracy
led by Nobel Peace Prize winner on
sang-soo cheek looks like it's one of
the most seats in the parliament which
will elect the new president but a law
passed by the military bands people with
foreign spouses or children from
becoming president and guess who's kids
in late husband have foreign citizenship
yep thanks Anne suci but she isn't
letting that get her down I said if we
are win and then early forms a
government I will be above the president
it's a very simplement the military will
retain a prominent voice in politics
because only 75 percent of the seats in
parliament can be contested by civilians
by keeping the rest the military ensures
we'll have a big say in the way the
country is run including with the next
president will be the United Nations
says man Mario hanger community is the
most persecuted minority in the world
the government won't give them
citizenship even though they lived in
Myanmar for generations they face
regular violence and discrimination and
hundreds of thousands have fled the
country so it's no surprise that they
along with some other minorities weren't
allowed to vote even Suchi herself has
been reluctant to speak out against the
oppression of the row hanga so while
this election is definitely a major step
for myanmar will it lead to a more
democratic future for all their
stateless impoverished and victims of
ongoing human rights abuses but how much
do you know about the row hey
of Myanmar I'm Dina to query and here's
a look at one of the world's most
persecuted minorities